watch this
foldable armrest
[Music]
this is a comprehensive review of the
sbb intercity 1 train c yes i have seen
so many flight seat review videos said
i've decided to make one about a train
actually alone right here so um
otherwise i wouldn't dare make this
video let's first explore the seat
itself the seat is quite wide
the leg room is absolutely comfortable i
can barely reach the other seat with my
foot if you consider the alleyway my leg
room is
infinity now in addition to that look at
this
the table
unfolds
crazy the space that you have here
absolutely magnificent and then these
very very neat cup holders
in addition to that every passenger gets
a very personal disposal bin
look at that absolutely phenomenal there
are air ducts built in under the seat
which make for a very comfortable
experience there is even some food on
the floor
so if i get hungry i know where i'll
find something
and there is even an on call button
right here in case you have an emergency
or want a drink or something i guess
everything's fair
now in whatever case that this disposal
bin here is full there is another
disposal then right there i
i literally don't have enough stuff to
dispose of to make use of all the
disposal bins
[Music]
let's check out the entertainment system
right here uh this shows various
destinations but uh i've been told one
can also play games and watch movies and
more things like that but for now i'm
i'm pretty happy with the programming
fire extinguisher absolutely nice to
have because you know the last thing you
want on a train is
fire
[Music]
now watch this
this is a giant toilet
[Music]
i can't even reach either wall
here we have some more disposal options
disposal
disposal for newspapers
disposal for waste
more fire extinguisher i'm starting to
think that fire is a larger problem on
trains than i might have realized
now this isn't even the best part yet
watch this
foldable armrest
unbelievable
[Music]
the intercity one is the absolute top of
its class i can only recommend this
train line i will never ever take
another train than this the onboard
service the seating arrangements the
legroom
food options the entertainment system
to perfection
give it a try go swiss trains
[Music]
you